today's video is kindly sponsored by
bright
sellers a monthly wine club that matches
you
with wine you'll love find out more
later in the video
hey 42 here one spring day in 1828
a disheveled teenage boy shuffled his
way into the city of noremberg
which at the time was part of the
kingdom of bavaria
the boy slowly made his way to the town
square
but when he arrived he just stood there
awkwardly holding an envelope out in
front of him
as if to hand it to someone only he
could see
after some time a local shoemaker took
pity on the boy
asking him if he needed any help instead
of answering
the boy simply pressed the envelope he
was carrying
into the shoemaker's hands the letter
was addressed to
captain friedrich von wessenick of the
local cavalry regiment
and so no doubt a little confused at
this point
the shoemaker led the way to the cavalry
headquarters
captain von vesinig was tracked down
without too much trouble
and the boy handed over his letter
without speaking
a word a deepening crease appeared
between the cavalryman's brows
as he began to read the letter was from
someone claiming to be the boy's
guardian
and it explained how the boy wished to
be trained as a cavalryman
all reasonable enough so far
but the note ended with an ultimatum
captain von wessenick was invited
to either hire the boy or
hang him
i enjoy cooking and i have a little
confession to make
i love to drink wine whilst i'm doing it
i honestly think there are a few small
pleasures in life that are better
than cracking open a new bottle of a
deep hearty red
whilst making dinner so that's why i
love bright cellars
a wine box experience that pairs you
with the wine you'll
love delivered straight to your door you
start by taking their quick online quiz
to determine your taste preferences
with fun questions like what's your
go-to alcoholic drink
your favorite juice and your favorite
kind of chocolate
then they match you with a selection of
top wines
that you are most likely to enjoy from
around the world
brightsellers actually uses an algorithm
to compare your preferences
with 18 different attributes so
you'll have full confidence that you'll
absolutely love
every single wine you receive and
they'll ship them right to your doorstep
via courier i also really like that
brightsellers educates you
about the wine you're drinking it feels
so much more intimate than store-bought
wine
and it makes each and every bottle a
unique experience
you can try bright cellars today by
clicking the link
in the description box below they are
giving my viewers an
amazing 60 off their first
four bottle box it seems the captain
wasn't a fan of either of those options
because instead of giving the boy a job
or murdering him on the spot he promptly
marched him directly to the local police
station
the police began to question the boy
trying to find out
who he was and what the hell he was up
to
but they were unable to get anything out
of him at least nothing intelligible
the boy showed no sign he understood
anything that was being said to him
and he didn't seem to be able to talk
beyond the few odd phrases he would
blurt house at random intervals
including i want to be a cavalryman like
my father was
and horse horse in the end
he was given a pencil and paper and
there
he was able to write just two words
his name casper hauser
from what i've told you about casper so
far i expect you'd assume
there was really something quite wrong
with him and you're probably right
but this was 1828 and people didn't tend
to have much time for the kinds of
illnesses you can't actually see
so instead of trying to help him in some
way the authority's labelled casper
a vagabond and threw him in jail
it was standard practice at the time to
lock people up for the
heinous crime of being homeless
not that casper seemed to begrudge this
punishment
and if anything he thrived in prison
though for reasons nobody could quite
understand
he refused to eat or drink anything
other than bread and water
extreme dietary requirements aside
the more cuspar interacted with his
guards and the string of
curious city officials who came to visit
him
the more he came out of his shell in
fact it isn't an exaggeration to say
that
kasper hauser underwent something of a
transformation
in the two months he spent behind bars
during that time his language skills
almost non-existent when he arrived in
norenburg
improved at an incredible rate and
before long he was able to tell his
captors
his remarkable life story up until that
point
it had been assumed casper was a
foundling
a child abandoned by his parents and
left to fend for himself somewhere out
there
in the vast forests of central europe
that would have been quite the tale in
itself
but as it turned out casper's upbringing
was far
far weirder than that for as long as he
could remember
casper had been kept against his will
in a tiny windowless room just two
meters long
one meter wide and one and a half meters
tall
the room well cell had been kept almost
pitch black at all times and had
contained nothing more
than a single straw bed and the small
carved wooden horse to play with
casper had absolutely no idea who he was
or why he was being kept in this way and
for almost his entire life he'd had no
contact with the outside world
whatsoever in fact his only sign there
was an outside world
beyond the walls of his tiny cell was
the occasional distant noise that
reached his ears and the tray of bread
and water that appeared by his bed each
morning
which explained why he refused to eat
anything else upon finding himself in
prison in nuremberg
this brutally limited existence
was all casper had known from infancy
until the age of 15 or 16.
when a hooded man began to visit his
tiny world
out of the blue the stranger who took
care never to reveal his face
taught casper his name and the few
phrases he'd known
when he arrived in norenburg the
stranger had also taught casper how to
write a few words
and even how to walk getting around
isn't all that important
when your entire known universe is two
meters long
casper's story was so shocking that it
soon spread
gaining him a certain kind of celebrity
status across the city
and as we all know celebrities are above
the law
and never have to actually suffer the
consequences of their crimes
so casper despite still technically
being
a vagabond was soon released from prison
over the next few years he would be
taken into the care of a string of
important people who took an interest in
his case
under the patronage of these new
benefactors
casper was clothed fed and given a roof
over his head
he was also educated and taught how to
behave
all proper-like but just when it seemed
that things were finally going well for
him
after the trauma of his upbringing
casper's past
caught up with him in a dramatic fashion
about a year after he first turned up in
nuremberg
casper was ambushed and attacked in his
home
by a hooded figure he was found shortly
afterwards
carrying in the cellar with blood
gushing from a wound on his forehead
and the assailant long gone it seemed
that somebody wanted casper hauser dead
the attack caused the 19th century
equivalent
of a media storm and before long
half of europe was talking about this
particular foundling
with an even more peculiar past it was
feared
another attempt on casper's life might
be imminent
and so he was put under armed guard by
the king of bavaria himself
ludwig the first but this increased
scrutiny
brought with it new questions just who
the hell was this boy
and why had he been hidden away in a
tiny cell
for most of his life was someone trying
to silence him and if so
what secrets did he know it wasn't long
before someone made an interesting
connection that seemed to provide
a neat little answer to all these
questions you see
casper had been born in 1812
around the same time as the infant
prince
of a noble family known as the house of
barden
tragically the young prince of baden had
passed away when he was just a few weeks
old
or had he according to some
the prince was very much alive but he'd
been snatched away
soon after he was born and disposed of
not killed but locked away
in a very small very sparse cell
and forgotten about for 16 long
years the motive for this baby napping
was clear
the prince had been the only son and
heir of the grand duke of house barden
and eliminating him caused the line of
succession to divert to a different part
of the family tree
when the duke passed away in 1818
it was a pretty wild theory but even
before
possible prince caspar showed up in 1828
there had been some strange rumors
swirling around the house of barden
including that the prince's mother never
saw her son's body
before he was buried it was enough
to get people wondering and it really
did seem that
somebody wanted casper out of the
picture
because just two years after the first
attempt on his life
unknown forces came for him once again
when he was attacked after being lord
into a secluded spot by a stranger
casper was stabbed in the chest and
this time the wound proved fatal
he died five days later just before
christmas
in 1833 he was 21 years old at the time
to heap another spoonful of mystery onto
casper's life story
a note its word scrawled in mirror
writing
was found near where the fatal stabbing
took place
this is what it said hauser will be able
to tell you
quite precisely how i look and from
where i am
to save hauser the effort i want to tell
you myself from where i come
i come from the bavarian border
on the river i will even tell you the
name
m l e it's almost
200 years since that letter was written
but as yet nobody has been able to
figure out
exactly what it means although we do
have a pretty good idea
who wrote it perhaps you have your
suspicions too
if not let's take a quick look back
through casper's story
a tale so outlandish it's almost
unbelievable
in fact let's face it it
is unbelievable according to casper
himself
he was raised in little more than a
well-appointed coffin
where he never learned to walk talk
or even stand and only ate bread and
water if caspar really had been brought
up under these conditions for almost his
entire childhood
the boy who eventually emerged into the
sunlight
in 1828 would have been irrevocably
damaged
both physically and mentally
casper certainly displayed real signs of
mental impairment when he first showed
up in nuremberg
but within the space of a few weeks he
went from hardly being able to speak a
word
to telling his entire life story in
minute detail
to put that into perspective in the
relatively small number of documented
cases
where children have been deprived of
language until their teenage years
few if any were able to master the
complexities of a language
to the level of a native speaker even
after decades of living a normal life
most modern retellings of casper's story
have him down as near enough crippled
when he arrived in norenburg
with a pained shuffling gate
soft feet that appeared to never have
been walked on
and eyes so sensitive to light he was
almost blind when the sun was up
in reality most of these details have
been added retrospectively
by people looking to add a bit more
credibility to the story
hauser may have been a little grubby
when he turned up in nuremberg
but he could work just fine and while
some sources suggest he had keen night
vision
he wasn't blinded by sunlight as for
that diet of his
anyone who ate only bread and water
would be dead from scurvy in a matter of
months
let alone 16 years so
yeah it probably shouldn't come as much
of a surprise that most people who spent
serious time researching casper house's
life
have come to the obvious conclusion he
was a fraud
a con man who told tall tales to gain
the attention
of important people as for all the
window dressing that came with the story
the cryptic notes and mysterious attacks
casper just
made it up the various letters involved
also strong evidence of having been
written by casper himself
and the attacks never really happened
casper simply wounded himself in order
to get attention
it's generally accepted that casper's
death was a weird case
of accidental suicide he tried to stab
himself up a little bit for effect and
ended up stabbing himself to death
it's beyond doubt that casper wasn't all
he claimed to be
but that doesn't make his story any less
interesting
we're talking about some utterly random
unremarkable guy from the 19th century
who managed to turn himself into an
international celebrity
just by chatting absolute
the mystery of casper hauser has
fascinated generation
after generation in the last 200 years
or so
during that time his story has cropped
up in the work of such literary legends
as
herman melville hans christian anderson
leo tolstoy
and robert a heinlein to name just a few
he's been the subject of songs at least
one film
several plays and countless
documentaries
casper may not have been a tragic figure
raised in
unspeakably terrible conditions he
claimed to be
but he was undoubtedly one of the most
successful attention seekers
ever to have lived and despite all we
know about him today
plenty of people still believe he was
the dirty secret
of one of europe's ruling families if
not
the house of baden then possibly
hungarian nobility
or british royalty over the years people
have made various attempts to prove
these connections
in 2002 samples of casper's dna were
analyzed by scientists
from the institute for forensic medicine
at the university of munster
in germany six samples were tested in
all
gathered from strands of casper's hair
and from his possessions
the samples were compared with a known
descendant of the house of baden
and whilst the results were inconclusive
they were similar enough that a familial
relationship
couldn't be ruled out just another
unexpected twist in the strange tale
of casper hauser thanks for watching